hello everyone and welcome to today's
session
lcms solutions for New Generation
Therapeutics I'm Susie Valdez of lab
roots and I will be your moderator for
today's presentation now I'd like to
invite everyone to participate by
submitting your questions during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the question box on the left toolbar
for further help or submit your concerns
in the ask a question box today's
session will be presented by Professor
Jonathan bones principal investigator at
the nibrt
for his research focusing on the
development and application of liquid
phase separations and mass spectometry
lcms and cems
for the characterization of complex
biopharmaceuticals for complete
biography of Professor Jonathan bones
please click on the biography button
within the presenter box information
Jonathan welcome sir you may now begin
your presentation
hi everybody and thanks for tuning in
it's a pleasure to be here today to tell
you about some of the work we've been
doing at live Arts where we've been
developing some LT math solutions for
New Generation Therapeutics
for those of you not familiar with this
neibert is the National Institute for
bioprocessing research and training and
worry world-class facility funded by the
Irish government based on the University
College Dublin campus in Dublin and
Ireland
what we have at library is a scaled down
gmp-like facility which allows us to do
a couple of different things
one of the main things which we do is
offer competency-based training in an
environment that replicates modern
industrial bioprocessing facilities
and really what we mean by this is that
numbers is a safe space it's there to
allow people to come to the facility and
hopefully again soon when travel permits
but to come into the building and to
learn by doing so effectively they get
to use read instrumentation to reunion
operation make any mistakes that might
happen but because this isn't on the
critical path they will effectively
learn by doing and ultimately return to
their own facility in a workplace ready
manner
the other thing which we do in library
is research about impact and we like to
work very closely in collaboratively
with people such as theirselves in the
bio pharmaceutical industry who are
making these life-changing molecules so
for example if you run into any bonds
and you need any assistance we're always
there to help to develop Solutions and
ultimately hopefully to get product on
the market quicker and to the people who
need them
over the past number of years we've been
really proud to collaborate with the
folks at Carmel Fisher Scientific and
together as part of this collaboration
it's allowed us to demonstrate the power
of their world-leading instrumentation
software and consumables for all aspects
of Bio pharmaceutical characterization
including some of what I'm actually
going to talk to you about today
I don't think it needs to be told but
the pastor has been a crazy one for
everybody and indeed for a thought here
in biofarma also
we all know covid-19 has caused huge
disruption but also has been a huge
driver for Innovation within the bio
pharmaceutical industry in the past year
we've seen massive changes in how we've
worked where we've had to implement
things like social distancing or even
being locked out of our facilities or
labs for quite some time in response to
government-induced lockdowns to try and
carbon the spread of the virus so it has
been massively disruptive but the one
thing which is impressive when we look
back over this time is really the speed
of which science itself has reacted and
indeed focusing on the positive we've
seen new therapies including things like
multiple vaccines and multiple antibody
therapies approved and deployed for the
treatment of covid-19 really at
Lightning Fast speeds so again
disability for science to react to apply
the Technologies which we use day in day
out now to do something for the benefit
of humanity has really been impressive
over the past while
and although covid-19 has grabbed all
the headlines there are still 53 novel
Therapeutics approved by the FDA in 2020
so it's worth not forgetting them and
these included 12 new monoclonal
antibodies two antibody drug conjugates
two antibody cocktail treatments not the
ones which we probably heard about for
the treatment of covert 19. in fact
these were treatments for Ebola virus
and also we've had two oligonucleotide
treatments
the good news for us is analysical
scientists is the speed of which the
industry is diversifying creates a huge
significant challenge
but despite the complexity of these new
molecular entities
the availability of cutting-edge
characterization Technologies is really
key to maintain the progress and to
translate this into successful outcomes
and ultimately to get these molecules
from these medicines to the patients who
need them
the need for high performing analysis
Solutions encompassing things like
liquify separations and high resolution
mass spectrometry and let's not forget
support of bioinformatics to make sense
of all this data has never been higher
so all in all despite the disturbances
over the past year it really has
probably never been a more exciting time
for science
so what I'd like to present you today
are four short stories and bio
pharmaceutical characterization which
are really some activities which my
group has undertaken over the past year
and these include the gobling
approaching Affinity chromatography to
high resolution orbital mass
spectrometry for the determination of
both typer and quality attributes of
maps and actually containing proteins
we are also going to talk to you about
some work we've done comparing the
performance of the thermal scientific
orbital stores to 40 Ms and our beloved
kids active plus where we've had a
pleasure to kind of compare both these
systems head to head for Native lcms
performance
we also talk to you about some rapid
subunus analysis using unbien
electrochemical reduction with high
resolution lcms for very rapid and very
simple analysis on the subunit levels or
the characterization of maps
and then finally we'll talk to you about
padside mapping of aav based gene
therapy using automated digestion and
high resolution lcms
so let's start with the first one where
we've investigated the coupling of
protein Affinity chromatography it's a
higher resolution orbitrop Ms for Rapid
assessments are both tighter on the
product quality attributes and this is
work which has been formed by Craig
Jakes in the group
so protein Affinity chromatography is a
key step for the purification of mobs
and SC Fusion proteins and this is
nothing new this is widely known it's
really the first bulk purification step
and a lot of the giant strike processing
of these molecules
the reason being is no one again is that
we can get very high capture affinity
for these molecules based on the
interaction of the SC and protein a to
allow for their blood purification
answer allow for the removal of mass of
a lot of the background contamination
present
we've also routinely used the thermal
scientific map pack protein a column for
antibody analysis and purification on
the small scale for again rapid title
determination using standard lcuv
there has been one previous report in
the literature where people have looked
a couple protein directly to my spec
but in this paper a really nice report
from Amazon what they looked at was the
coupling of the system but using
yourself a makeup flow so now for a
denatured intact Mass analysis so even
though the data was quite nice we wanted
to look at simplification of the system
and ultimately utilization but native
Mass spectrometry
and we did this
and we watched that as they explore this
see what it could actually do and to use
this as the record as a rapid method
promote tighter determination and also
the assessment of the pqas or the
product quality attributes as quick as
we could because ultimately our goal
with this Supply is in near real time
for online process monitoring and you
can see an example chromatogram on the
inside on Floyd here whereby we could
Implement a five minutes methods where
we could take our samples from our
process via drug substance theater
products inject the monster map pack
protein Aid divert the initial and flow
through components out to waste so we
didn't have any issues in terms of force
contamination and then do our front
solution off the column into the mass
spectrometer and get some very nice and
impressive data so I'm going to talk to
you back now
so to show you what this looked like
as mentions this is performed using the
map approaching a column A
thermoscientific factors Flex uhplc
couple II are thermal scientific two
exact a few HMR hybrid quadrupole
orbital Mass spectrometer and the data
which you see on the screen at the
moment was startup which was generated
using fabrication lab as a model
antibody
so using the method outlined in the
previous slide wherein we could do our
loading our rapid front pollution and
use that two minute diverse valve to get
rid of all those additional components
of the star still in the same material
that look right to waste we get this
very nice sharp chromatographic Peak we
can then look and see what the Mass
Spectrum looks like and indeed it is
that Costco charge reduced native
looking Spectrum which is nice this is
what we wanted to achieve because
ultimately due to the increased spatial
spectral resolution present we can
perform very high efficient
deconvolution and you can see this then
on the right hand part where you get to
see what the deconvoluted mass data
looks like which is indeed very nice
we're getting a lot of information in
this case with regard to the causalation
present and its Associated pairing so
one of the things when we thought about
this and when you think about property
name methods is you have loading of the
sample under standard physiological
conditions generally pH 7 7.4 and we
then do that from solution by dropping
the pH in quite fast so our question was
why are we getting native like Mass
Spectra a pH 2.5 which in this case was
the illusion conditions performed
so to investigate this further we
actually did a PK titration using Cloud
exclusion chromatography couple to
Native Mass spectrometry again Anarchy
in fact a few HMR instrument
so Greg in this case took the antibody
he took 1000 protein a and mixed them
together and performed the analysis
using mobile phases and buffers under
various conditions pH as indicated on
the right hand portion of the
chromatogram so you can see on the left
hand panel of the slide
the nice thing with this as well is that
even though protein a chromatography is
really what we would say a bread and
butter technique something which
everybody uses so it really hasn't been
a huge amount in the literature which
describes the actual Stoichiometry of
the complex forms there's some studies
and we have to go back quite a long time
to find these performed using a variety
of methods but there is some consistency
some of which say the complex is one to
one in terms of the approaching a
antibody and some of which say it's two
to one two antibodies to one protein a
molecule but when we perform the
analysis here and you can see as
indicated with the perpetary angles the
complex forms we only ever thought add a
one-to-one stoichiometry
the nice thing with the data when we go
through this and actually look at the pH
dependency we can see the complex is
rapidly formed and present really above
ph5
as we lower the ph we then start to see
not the complex forming and only the
protein a and the antibody present and
indeed interestingly
as we went down to lower pH in this case
we also thought like Distortion of the
charge envelope from the classical
charge reduced native locking charge
envelope to some lines appearing as
lower arm over the Z values potentially
indicating that there might be some sort
of reversible change in the structure
happening to allow for increased charge
to be uptaken under the Spectrum to
become distorted so this is interesting
it gave us an indication as to this pH
behavior of the actual
um the system but the nice thing again
with this when we did our protein Aid
directly coupled to mass spectrometry we
didn't see this effect and we assumed
that this is actually kinetic in terms
of the illusion from the column and
transfer into the instrument is so fast
compared to the SEC experiments for the
residence time in the column is much
longer so we don't see these effects and
therefore we have no issues in terms of
this Distortion of the spectrum and its
usability for deconvolution afterwards
what we also wanted to do then was to
evaluate the performance of the methods
because again if this must be interested
we want it to be linear and reproducible
and all those standard things would
evaluate under IC hq2
so again Craig here looked at us various
different levels of antibody injection
and so really nice linearity over and up
to 100 microgram transactions down
column he also looked at the performance
at the higher and the lower levels to
see how the actual mass back performance
was and you can see again from the data
on screen very nicely till we get
beautiful Spectra at both the higher and
lower points which again upon
deconvolution gives equivalent data the
only thing with this is expected as we
go to lower and lower quantities then we
do see an Ever Society increase in the
deviation of BPM methocracy plus
everything regardless of this was still
below our 25 PPM acceptable limit so
even though for very low levels the
system works really really well and
gives a very nice and usable data
the next thing which gray did then was
to evaluate applicability to different
molecules containing an FC region so in
this case he looks a number of different
antibodies are very in complexity just
based on other post-transulation
modifications such as C terminal license
clipping or glycosidation for example
cytocin lab which is known to have the
additions like consolation size in the
Fab region so again you can see very
nicely from the central panel The
increased complexity of the Specter with
increased complexity of the molecule but
regardless of this
due to the analysis on their nation-like
conditions we capture that increased
space and spectral resolution which
allows for efficient deconvolution and
annotation of quite a number of pqas in
the associated de convoluted Spectrum
he also looked at an ADC milic in this
case a system linked ABC mimic where the
utilization of native-like conditions
was important to maintain any particular
non-covalent interactions or to minimize
stress in the molecule which might cause
the molecule to unwind or fall apart so
again this works very very nicely you
can see the Spectrum very complicated in
this case due to both the presence of
the conjugated drug but also the
glycosylation present in the fce region
but again we could deconvolute this and
get useful data which allow for
annotation on the back end
the last thing which we did as part of
the study was to bring this to the
process and see how it might actually
behave in this case in an outline format
so we run a number of bioreactors using
the standards show the igg-1 producing
process collecting samples of different
days
and you can see three those days shown
on the slide here so the nice thing
again with this really what we're
looking is the comparison of the colors
between the graph not across an
individual graph you'll see the
conditioned use labeled on the x-axis
below but with this we can track various
different attributes again in particular
glycosylation and garlic translation in
this case which you can see from
particularly the green and purple bars
how it changes in response to the
process age and the process conditions
as we go forward
for all in all the scoping approaching a
uh directly to Ms to generate these
native like Ms Spectra gives us a lot of
information in a very rapid method and
it's something which we're now exploring
further to really kind of determine its
full of utility
the next thing which I want to talk to
you about is the performance of the EQ X
Factor plus and the orbital explorers to
40 Ms for Native lcms based applications
and this case is work which was done by
Sarah corello and flarian field service
in the group
we previously presented initial
evaluations of the orbitrop Explorers
240 MF for a variety of different
biopharmaceutical applications
and these included things for example
native lcms intact Mass analysis subunit
analysis unpatched mapping applications
but of all the things we did with the
system what really kind of blew us away
was the performance of the system under
native conditions for Native ltms
applications
for example things like size exclusion
or pH gradient charge experience
analysis coupled directly to the system
so when we had a bit more time we then
wanted to understand what's the actual
relative bands particularly in
sensitivity of the orbitrage Explorers
240 versus the two exacto Plus
so you can see the experimental
conditions that were performed on both
systems to either for size exclusion or
pH gradient charge variance analysis
shown on screen here at the moment
but let's have a look at the data
so from the orbital explorers you can
see here for some slides exclusion data
various amounts of
antibody which were injectors onto the
column under various different
resolution settings
you can see the associated chromatograms
on the left the native Ms Spectrum in
the center panel and then an expansion
of thus on the right hand side
so we can look quite clearly here and
see and pick settings which allow us to
have obviously a sufficient number of
points per Peak if we want to have a
look at any sort of quantitative
applications we can look and see how the
Spectra itself looks like and look at
the sensitivity and then again Mass this
across as the resolution value to make
sure that we have that power to separate
any neroid the barric interference to
micro present within that Spectrum
we did the same experiments obviously as
part of the comparison on the Q exactly
plus
again you can see it here quite
graphically as we increase the
resolution settings we start to see that
dissolution of the signal really just
due to the longer transiting times and
that slight loss of sensitivity
but to kind of do this and to lock this
head-to-head we actually wanted to
compare this in terms of things to noise
level and that's what you can see here
four again one particularly extracted
charge State
um the screen at present again
Barbershop explorers data on the left
hand side in red and the Q exactive Plus
data on the right hand side in the blue
color
the resolution setting is used indicated
on the left hand panel
so quite nicely here you can see the
signature noise that I've determined
from the actual experimental data and as
expected and as we had observed
previously but now with an actual number
on them to determine what they were we
can see that increase in signature noise
which we get using the orbit traffic
floors for Native lcms applications in
this case size exclusion hyphenated
directly to the instrument
we looked at this again under different
conditions for example Now using
different lows on columns
color scheme is the same so you can see
how each instrument behaves at both a 50
microgram or 25 nanogram on-column load
so again beautiful native Ms Spectra
obtained and then the expansion of an
individual chart stays over on the right
hand side
and really then as we go through the
process of doing our deconvolution
within biopharma finder we can see
really again as expected the associated
PPM or Johnson math accuracy on the
writing site and as expectors appear
because we have a higher signal
intensity coming from our traffic Stars
we can actually maintain the mass
accuracy to a higher level than we had
seen slightly before on the Queue with
active Plus but again there's not a
massive difference between the two of
them it allows us to really kind of see
what the benefit ultimately is
for some pH gradient charge variant
workflows now in this case here we
looked at Humira and we previously
characterized human Europe before it has
quite a complex charge variant profile
resulting not only from the peak seen on
screen with the different lysine
variants but also from another a number
of acidic variants are very low levels
with different degrees of deamidation
present on the molecule what you see
here for this zero two serum zero Z term
lysine variant is an expansion of data
in the bubble or by different amounts of
your mirror runs acted on column
again Barbershop explorers 240 in red
two exactly plus in blue
and you can see the associated signature
noise determined for each of those
injections indicated on the charge State
expansion
the nice thing with this
for some of the initial experiments we
have performed as part of the
development of this methodology on QE
plus we used 100 micrograms but now on
the orbitrak Explorer C40 at 10 times
the lower on column sample load we have
a much harder segment to noise ratio so
again a quantitative estimation of how
far we can increase sensitivity on the
Explorers 240.
if we look now at the lower variance in
this case the form which also choose the
German license present even though
overall the relative abundance of it is
quite low again when we look at the
charge study expansion and look at the
associated loadings keeping the color
scheme again red for explorers 240
Bluetooth exactly plus we can see again
even for this low level of variant at
the presence our signature noise for low
on-column loadings with the Explorer 340
it's Superior to what we had observed
through QX access Plus so it really does
allow for quite a big bounce and
sensitivity for Native lcms applications
which we really like because it
maintains and preserves the genomic
range of modifications that are present
on these complex molecules one final
example we looked at was again using the
sigma ADC mimic and for example as you
see on screen here this is a stochastic
system linked ABC mimic where we have
the different forms of the presence
between 0 2 4 6 and 8 of this model
conjugated drug on the particular
antibody itself
so one of the things that you must
determine for these adcs is the drug to
antibody Ratio or the DAR and this can
be done using things like hydrophobic
interaction or indeed intact native math
analysis and that's what we're
interested in here
so when we perform this you can see what
the data looks like again maintaining
the color scheme as indicated on flight
and we get this beautiful Spectra
beautiful Spectra complex where we see
the amount of information again because
we have the conjugation of the drug to
the antibody and also the glycans
present in the FC region but really what
there's no here is when we look at the
expansion in the gray box on the right
hand side
um the keyword Factor plus we actually
start to lose the information as we
reduce the sample loading for the jar 0
and R8 form I know this is quite hard to
see I appreciate it it's quite small
here but when we look at the same data
moving upwards from the information
generated on the orbitrop Explorers 240.
even though these forms are present to
no levels and as we reduce the on column
sample loading we still have sufficient
signal presence to left for the
efficiency convolution and The
annotation of the drug to antibody ratio
moving on the third short story to talk
about today is some rapid subunit
analysis of mobs which we've performed
using online electrochemical reduction
and the data which you see now was work
which was performed by Thomas Morgan
within the group
so Sylvia's announces that mobs is a
pretty standard workflow and I'm sure
you guys are all familiar with this and
it's traditionally performed using
things like chemical reduction so where
we either have reducing agents such as
dtt teenager engaging plus of clonidine
there's a bit of sample prep a bit of
time involved in this it takes some time
to have these reactions perform
efficiently
um or we can combine this again with
things like ideas app protease digestion
if we want to insert a form or heavy
chain light chain form rft over two rft
and our light and our light chain again
very very standard workflow things which
are all pretty much familiar with
but in this case what we wanted to look
and see was could we actually speed this
up by getting rid of the sample prep
altogether and Performing the reduction
step using electrochemistry online and
in this case the device used was the
object scientific Rock series potential
status
and the reason with this was again to
see if we could do our sample
preparation quickly but also then if we
could do this under non-genatron
conditions again thinking back to some
of the you know complex molecular
formats where we may want to have a look
at Labor modifications non-covalent dark
interactions or other things whereby
sample preparation major disrupt this
and not give us the information that we
need
so to perform this the setup was as
follows we use the thermal scientific
pancreas dual U hblc we had the
anti-scientific roxic potential sub cell
inline you'll see the plumbing of this
shortly we use two map or P reverse
phase columns one is a trap and one is a
non-muskin column we hyphenated this
either to our Q X active Plus or to our
Arbitrage explorers 240 and arithm was
performed including the electrochemical
aspect under the control of Pharma
scientific romidian 7.2 CDs system
in terms of the electrochemical cell
itself the nice thing with this is that
it offers state-of-the-art simple to use
electronics and for the reduction
purposes effectively this is a step wave
a very quick step wave so when sellers
off we don't get reduction but when we
turn on the reduction potential
obviously we have the electrochemistry
happening which allows for the reduction
of the disulfide bonds and if actually
the splitting of the molecule into
individual blockchain and heavy chains
to set this up we wanted to do this in
line so effective this would allow us to
use the electrochemical cell as I said
for sample prep
and we did this basically using the
unique capabilities of the Vanquish duo
with the single switching valve for
effectively it bind and loose uh very
standard approach
so in this case here we have the first
pump from the Dual system providing the
mobile phase which is Nest 3 to allow
for the online reduction we could turn
this alarm allow the reduction to happen
and then capture the reduced heavy chain
and night chain on our trap column then
when we're ready we simply switch the
column and use the second pump to
provide the analyst for mobile phases to
eluse from the trap carry on to the on
the screen column allow the separation
to happen
and ultimately the nla for the high
resolution Mass back detection
quite simple and quite standard
approaches
so Thomas's parses did a lot of the
optimization of the electrochemical
reduction Style
and the nice thing as you see on top
here with the sell-off we get our intact
antibody
with the salon initially using water we
could see some reduction but we were
getting a variety of different species
present most likely due to incomplete
reduction after interchange I sulfur
bonds both under heavy and the byte end
of theft
and you can see this again from the
associated Ms data shown on the right
hand part of the slide
so when we looked at the data Thomas
also did a model of the distribution of
the masses and charge States and we
could see now based on this and what the
experimental data looked like so we were
somewhere in between from a fully
reduced and a fully omrogen species
what we noticed them with this was
because of the conditions really with
the 100 water we were hitting the
kinetic barrier so using those
particular conditions we were getting
some reduction but unfortunately it was
often possible to increase the reduction
further with the applied Electro
potential so we wanted to investigate
this and see if we could find a solution
and it was quite simple really as he
worked through this he saw some simple
things like increasing the temperature
and the addition of the small amount of
solvent allowed for relaxation of the
territory structure for more efficient
reduction and as we go through these you
can see the different conditions as
indicated on the chromaticons in the
left hand side we can go from incomplete
reduction to complete reduction
we can also practice quite nicely based
on the change in retention time on the
map RP column because as we reduce into
nature obviously we expose more
hydrophobic residues and again using the
associated Ms data we can see how the
charge stays change changes from where
we have incomplete reduction to the more
complete reduction we see this very
nicely move in the associated Mass
Spectra and when Thomas again did the
isotopic modeling based on charge stage
again now we can see as we go from this
intermediate species with incomplete
reduction to the complete reduced
species very nicely so we have the
confidence with the conditions used
allowed for complete reduction in a very
rapid time frame
the nice thing with this then was that
we could combine this with IDs protea
suggestion to allow us to get our
standard SC over 2 by chain and St
separation
so the digestion was performed in
solution offline and then the sample was
taken and ejected directly onto the
system setup as outlined previously
through the Roxy before we turn the cell
on use the reducing Square arrays to
allow us to actually do the inter and
interchange disulfide reduction
we capture the selectivity of Separation
on the map Mark RP and then we get the
beautiful high resolution
Ms data as indicated on the bottom of
the slide here indicating complete
reduction
and when we do the deconvolution very
very nice and high mass accuracy
so again just a quick outline of what we
can do in this regards where we've
Incorporated this online reduction to
minimize sample prep and Sample handling
and we're City scoring this to see what
else we might be able to do with this on
both the intact subunus and indeed on
the peptide level
very quickly the last short story I want
to tell you about today is some of the
work we've done with the peptide mapping
of aav based gene therapy using
automated digestion on high resolution
lcms
and again this work was performed in the
lab like Felipe Guapo and Josh Smith
one of the key things with this is that
AV based gene therapy is extremely
complicated to work with due to the
limited quantities of protein to the
present despite the high cuts of number
or high viral genome counts so we hear
these incredibly large numbers but
unfortunately it doesn't translate to
protein and we end up dealing with quite
Trace samples
additionally due to the sequence
degeneracy across the viral capsa
proteins The annotation of the location
of post-transellation modifications is
very very complex
we've had the associated guidance from
The Regulators as shown here cut from
the FTA and they require for CMT aspects
of gene therapy submissions methods
capable of characterization and agency
testing analysis of process related
impurities and indeed analysis of
product relation impurities for example
the false empty cups of ratiosk and the
nice thing with all these Technologies
is that ltms really fits the build
but we've looked at this so far is for
sequence verification and PGM assessment
as part of the identity testing and
characterization workflow and we've also
performed the announcements of residual
wholesale proteins present on the
infinity purified aav which again is a
challenge based in sensitivity to
address the process related impurities
and we'll show you briefly some of the
data which has been generated so far
so a key challenge when we started to do
pattern mapping workflows and again
we're all familiar with how we do this
for antibodies and recombinant proteins
Plus for aav to achieve High sequence
coverage we have to actually look at a
number of different influence we wanted
to use the thermal scientific smart
digest kits on the Kingfisher zero
factor of prime purification system
based on the controls which we guessed
using the automation are capability of
the zero Prime
you'll see shown on slide here tree
overlay chromatograms and from the
original matrixon we really didn't get
much signal back we got quite low
sequence coverage for all the AED
proteins
we invested smart climate friction as
well this was a little bit better but
not much but really what we found was by
using the smartest person magnetic kit
option again with the Kingfisher Jeweler
Prime to really control the digestion we
could get really nice suggestion of the
capsids and in these complete sequence
coverage of the individual cups of
protein presence
we overlaid this in terms of the
individual protein sequence in this case
shown on slide it's a faster sequence
for vp1 and this basically uses the
colors hopefully you can see the key up
here on the right hand side but it
allows us to annotate the sequence
coverage following analysis in biofarm
refiner using the different proteases
and see where we have either complete or
rather we have gaps as we perform the
Pepsi mapping workflow you can again see
conditions experiment conditions
annotated over here on the right hand
side of the slide
and from this we've actually gone
forward with the magnetic smart pets and
on killing Fisher zero Prime for routine
aav based gene therapy acid mapping
applications
the last thing which we've done in this
case was to look at the analysis of
residual wholesale proteins in aav
products again because it was a peptide
Center technique
um rather than looking at some of the
more complex characterization aspects we
just kept going in that regard
so the thing which we did here was to
collect samples of Av which had been
subjected to efficiency purification
using the thermoscientific porous
capture select aavx Affinity resin so we
had samples which was collected
obviously in the harbor circles or
fluids and then samples which was
Infinity purifies there afterwards and
it was a substituency pair of example we
wanted to look at to determine the
levels of residual atps in the process
present on those capsules the workflow
which we use again involves magnetic
bead-based digestion on the Kingfisher
General Prime and following that the
samples were analyzed using the
orbustrophic stores 240 with Nano
reverse phase chromatography from the
front end and also on our Q exactly plus
with Nano LT
data was performed or got announced
Safari was performed using proteum
Discoverer 2.5
in terms of what we got back you can see
here in terms of both the Venn diagrams
and then also the bar graph the
information was quite interesting really
so for these essentially purified
samples if we search the data
individually so for example either the
Explorer 340 data on its own or the Q
executive Plus data on its own you can
see if there was a bit of disparity in
the data and again not surprising as
we've seen based on the
increased sensitivity we've been able to
achieve using explorers 240.
but it's not assisting the queue exactly
we're often doing a good job here it's
important to know fast if we look then
over here on the essential portion where
we can compare and search the data
together
in this case using the workflow in
program discover you can see that the
majority of these HEB contaminants
were also found in the queue exotic data
as well so it uses obviously the search
output from the storage 240 to
effectively retrain on the data Flash
and then to go back and look for these
in yourself unifies in the sequence so
this is quite nice we have the
conference we weren't losing anything
plus it comes down to the instrument
sensitivity and as you see over here on
the bar graph simply on the Explorers
340 we're identifying more peptides per
protein so more peptides per hcp present
and ultimately an increased number of
hcps
so to look forward into the data we did
simple things like a gene ontology
annotation and visualization using
rubigo just to see what the actual
information might look like
so you can see for both molecular
function and biological process again
our QE data up top versus the Explorers
240 data then bottom
quite visually in this case really just
based on the number of spots or
annotated go terms and indeed the
coloring of those go terms simply based
on the increased sensitivity on
explorers 240 we see more and the really
nice thing with this now when we look at
some of those identified go terms we
start to actually pick up hcps presence
on the viral capsids which were
associated with the cellular processes
of actual manufacturing expression at
that particular viral Cactus so it gives
us a nice indication in terms of the
biological processes happening during
the actual bioprocess itself and the
repertoire then the proteins involves
which may be still associated with the
cartilage and pass through Affinity
purification and ultimately require a
polishing step as part of the DSP
so that's going to ask me some
information that I wanted to share with
you as part of these four quick stories
based on their recent activities or uh
in buyer processing but as mentioned
today there's been quite a number of
people involved so to wrap up to
acknowledge everybody who's been
involved as part of the team at the
library again to our collaborators of
antech scientific for the work which
we've done with the online
electrochemistry
to our collaborators at Avi for the work
we've done on the gene therapy
application and to the huge number of
collaborators as part of our interaction
with Pharma scientific who not only are
fantastic scientists but fantastic
people to work with also
thank you so much for your attention
listening and I'm happy to answer any
questions on any aspects what you've
seen did you may have thanks so much
thank you Jonathan for that informative
presentation if you have any questions
please
email Jonathan directly at
jonathan.bones at
nibrt dot IE before we go
we're going to go ahead and do our live
audience
so our first question coming in
is what are some of the challenges that
you have faced with aav characterization
thanks for the question Susie the
biggest challenge we face really has
been imagine material uh it's been a
whole new experience for us I think when
we've been working with proteins before
we've been used to having make promotes
like Solutions with aav we hear all
these huge numbers but unfortunately
they don't equate into protein demands
so now we're dealing with microgram
promote Solutions or lower so it brings
a whole new challenge with regard to the
need for sensitivity the need for lower
floor separations Etc but these things
are fundamental the Technology Solutions
are there thankfully it's just a matter
of I suppose rethinking some of the
things that we classically do
thank you so much and Jonathan can you
comment on load and illusion solvents
for protein AMS
yeah for sure so the illusion solvents
that we use for all a monument
state-based buffers
um just a different BHS to keep
everything volatile and mask back
friendly they worked really well we did
quite a bit of optimization um that'll
all be included in that publication
which was mentioned for that section of
the talk
um the other thing with the loading was
that we found the method was really
sensitive uh probably slightly more so
than the associated GB detections that
we were using also so we could see uh
you know way less than a microgram and
column again all that information uh
including the validation parameters
which were undertaken will be included
in the associated publication
thank you very much and again I want to
thank our audience for these great
questions we have time for one more
question and any questions we don't get
time for today you can email directly to
Jonathan our last question Jonathan how
versatile is the electrochemical
reduction method
it was really versatile through the um
we've used it a lot on inside protein
and subunits as shown today it's work
which were ought to be continuing at the
moment to see what else we can do with
this looking at a variety of different
molecules both antibodies in more
complex formats it requires a little bit
of optimization but once we got it up
and running it was really cool it allows
us to speed things up and generate some
nice data
Jonathan I want to thank you again for
your important presentation and your
research and again I want to thank our
audience for joining us today we hope
you guys enjoy the rest of the event
take care everyone bye-bye